one two three
they were making pants t-shirts trousers
shorts for brands such as [ __ ] walmart
or primark we are in dhaka the capital
city of bangladesh april 24
2013. on that day garment workers didn't
know what to expect when they arrived at
their workplace the rana plaza
the day before the owners of the
building had been informed of cracks in
the structure by the workers themselves
but they ignored the warnings and forced
them to get back to work or they
wouldn't be paid
the building collapsed leaving more than
one thousand deaths and around 2 400
injured workers the deadliest accident
in the garment
industry the story is still relevant
today because it concerns the brands
that we wear every day all over europe
the companies the owners of the brands
somehow allowed this to happen because
they didn't check on the working
conditions of their subcontractors
and it wasn't the first time
according to the european commission
today 160 million children worldwide are
in child labour that is one in 10
children in the world
nearly half of these children are
performing dangerous work
at the same time 25 million people
worldwide are in a situation of forced
labor
[Music]
the eu led by the s d group wants to
improve the situation now proposing a
ban on forced labor as well as a law to
foster sustainable and responsible
corporate behavior throughout the entire
supply chain of companies
so how can we make sure that the clothes
we wear are made responsibly or that the
coffee we drink has been collected on
the fair conditions or that the phone we
use doesn't contain any materials
extracted through forced labor in one
word how can we make sure that companies
do their due diligence let's find out in
this new episode of what's left
[Music]
take a t-shirt
have you ever asked yourself the
question how is it made there are
different steps to manufacture a t-shirt
it starts from creating its design and
sample cutting to mass production sewing
and cutting
along the process big garment companies
very often outsource the production
abroad
mostly in asia
the process from the creation of the
product to selling it in shops is called
the supply chain
so how do we make sure that social and
environmental standards as well as basic
human rights are being respected along
the entire supply chain of companies
this is exactly what due diligence is
all about
making sure that companies act
responsibly and giving access to justice
to anyone who has been a victim of a
company's wrongdoings
today eu companies are only encouraged
to behave responsibly but no legal
obligations are imposed on them and this
is exactly why the smd group in the
european parliament started this battle
to know more about it we met the snd mep
lara walters who is in charge of this
file for the european parliament due
diligence is a duty of care essentially
and it's a duty of care for companies
and it's about environment human rights
and governance so ultimately what this
is about is companies investigating
what's going on in their value chains
and no longer saying we didn't know
about
deforestation forced labor
and those kinds of things we don't have
a law at the moment everything that's
there at the moment is voluntary what we
need companies to do is really take
responsibility and proactively go look
at the problems that are most real to
them in their value chains so what we
need to do is really make sure that
there's accountability responsibility
that lies with the company and not make
this into some tick box exercise that
somebody somewhere in compliance is
responsible for what i want is for ceos
of companies board rooms to take
responsibility to know what's going on
and to personally get involved in this
process so we need to make sure that
there's um that there's a a that there's
access to justice we need to make sure
that it's it's it's possible for for
local communities and so forth to take
big companies to court uh we need to
make sure that they're they're
facilitated in doing that if needed um
and we need to make sure that there's
remedy at all at the end of this ideally
of course this law will prevent any
problems
but if problems cannot be prevented then
we need to make sure there's access to
justice and we need to make sure that
there's remedy that's satisfying we had
a huge amount of negotiating to do to
get to this point there was a huge
amount of
um
talking about this almost education i
would say on what are the problems
what's already being done and so forth
for us to be able to get to the
consensus that we reached that really
wasn't easy my role in that was
mediating facilitating and pushing and
and so as the draft person i was of
course very proud that we were able to
get a big majority on this and my role
going forward will be to really get this
law across the line
after the european parliament repeatedly
called for a law on due diligence fought
for by the progressives the european
commission eventually came up with
proposals
but the progressives weren't alone in
this fight
ngos and civil society have been been
vital in raising awareness in bringing
examples of wrongdoing
to our attention and that's helped
hugely with political momentum
i think they need to be involved in the
process of making this legislation to
make sure that we can actually have an
impact on the ground
we had the opportunity to discuss with
one of the co-founders of these ngos
patrick ali global witness is a pioneer
ngo defending human rights and natural
resources through its investigative work
and campaigning the ngo started raising
awareness about the crimes of the khmer
rouge in cambodia and put a spotlight on
the illegal conflict diamonds that
financed bloody wars in western africa
in the 90s
well i think the broad proposal of
a law on due diligence is a global game
changer
having worked in many parts of the world
where
you know companies have traded in timber
or diamonds whatever the fun conflict or
the result in tremendous
environmental damage or human rights
abuses and there's no kind of catch-all
thing to get them
if they have to abide by this law then i
think that's incredibly powerful
companies hate
regulation
and which is precisely the reason you
probably should have it it's a
fundamental point
that
if you start a massive project whether
that's agribusiness or a mine or a
hydroelectric dam in somewhere where
you're not wanted
a the people
are going to protest
um
usually they're the ones that suffer for
that we document annual killings of land
and environmental defenders in 2020 it
was 227 people four people a week at
least murdered
for protesting against projects there
are other areas
of improvement which are essential
one of which is
right now as the draft goes companies
can
devolve responsibility down the chain
and so if if a supplier of you know the
big company says okay you know they come
to say okay we want you to guarantee
that there's no forced labor in the
supply chain and that company says yeah
okay we'll guarantee it that doesn't
actually guarantee there's no forced
labour in the supply chain
it guarantees that the big company
isn't going to get paid my story because
they're going to blame the one down the
line so that needs to change
so we just produced this report which
shows that in fact
lots of the minerals are coming from
mines where there are militias
where there is child labour
some minds which are completely
unproductive are being recorded as
providing you know vast amounts of
minerals
and even
officials of its key
have been directly involved
and taking a cut we believe
from some of those deals but just a
really good example of something which
is high profile internationally accepted
actually isn't working and another thing
which is um missing really in the in the
law right now
is the role of finance we've produced a
lot of reports recently for example on
the beef industry and the financing of
the beef industry in brazil the beef
industry in brazil is responsible for 60
percent of the deforestation
in that country the money from like the
one of the world's biggest producers jbs
the money's coming from western banks
that's who's financing them so we have
to have the banks and the financiers
included in this because without the
money these developments can't happen
and if the money
continues then they will continue to
happen
fabricated
the french mep and philosopher rafael
glucksman has for years been drawing the
world's attention to the chinese
regime's crimes against the rigors a
muslim ethnic minority from the
northwestern region of xinjiang
china the largest supplier of goods in
the world is believed to detain more
than one million rigors in detention
camps and to force them into work
some big fashion firms are believed to
have benefited from this modern form of
slavery
we asked rafael glicksman if this
european law on due diligence could help
the situations of rigors in china
this is
foreign
foreign
so will the long-awaited rule book on
sustainable due diligence for companies
be a game changer the socialists and
democrats in the european parliament are
driving this legislation and fighting so
that no company can make profits selling
in the eu market by abusing workers or
by polluting our planet this is not
business as usual